[Music]
Red Dead Redemption 2 has finally hit
stores with was arguably one of the
biggest games ever
whether you've completed it or can't be
bothered to put in the kind of 100 hour
work week that Rockstar demands in order
to see the end I'm here to break down
what happens using reviews cutscenes and
spoiler talks I've put together a
breakdown of both endings for the game
as well as the epilogue scene there will
be heavy spoilers for both and this is
your last chance to avoid temptation and
turn this video off without the way I'm
definition and I play the game so you
don't have to buy the games ending the
Dutch vandal in gang is in complete
disarray Arthur who at this point is
dying of tuberculosis realizes that he
hasn't got long left for this world and
decides to try and be a good man for
once in his final few days he rescues
John and Sadie and reunites with Abigail
in order to showcase that he has turned
over a new leaf counter-attacking this
good karma is Dutch the character
successfully manages to turn the web PT
tribe and eagle flies against the US
Army and uses their conflict as an
opportunity for one final score they
successfully robbed the u.s. payroll as
onboard the Train and on the most part
it's a great payout for Doug and Myka
John however is shot and presumed dead
during the heist whilst abigail is
abducted by the Pinkertons Dutch shows
his true colors and leaves Abigail to
her fate which leaves the task rescuing
her for Arthur and Sadie both storm van
Hoorn and managed to kill agent Miller
who reveals that Myka was in fact the
Pinkerton Rats Arthur returns to the
camp to reveal as to Dutch who refuses
to accept it John two turns up and
confronts Dutch about leaving him for
dead the camp are forced to scatter
before they can fully settle their
differences and it is at this point that
the player is given a choice on
affecting the game's outcome you can
either help John or go back for the
money either option ends with Arthur
Amica getting into a fight which forces
Dutch to intervene Dutch appears torn on
who to kill due to the new knowledge
that Meeker is now
but instead of killing either he simply
walks away you choice earlier changes
the fate of Arthur in some respects but
still does not alter the fact that he
dies
greedy players who went back for the
money will eventually be killed by Myka
however players that went back and
helped John will see Arthur come to the
realization that in the end he was a
good person and they will be treated to
the character looking out over a
beautiful view before succumbing to the
tuberculosis
it's a slightly dour note to end on as
Arthur dies either way and Dutch amico
both get to fight another day however
the game possesses an epilogue that ties
up all these loose ends and leads into
the rest of the games in the series we
fast forward a few years and players are
now in the shoes of John Marston who
fans will of course recognize as the
protagonist from Red Dead Redemption
John works as a farmhand with Abigail
and is forced to take up guns once more
in order to protect innocent people at
the ranch though Abigail is disappointed
by this John fights to prove that he can
change his ways and sets out to build
Beaches hope on a recently acquired plot
of land John finds happiness with
Abigail Eyre and during his time lends
information about Micah's whereabouts
John eventually tracks Meeker and a
broken-down dirge in the standoff Dutch
kills Myka and disappears into the night
desperate to leave the life behind that
destroyed him whether this was because
of the betrayal that they did to Arthur
or just that Dutch had had enough of
Micah's lies is open to interpretation
but it's great that the character found
redemption much in the same way that
Arthur did John recovers the money and
returns to Abigail and in the
post-credits scene we learn how at Garos
discovered John's location and the game
beautifully sets up the events that
happen in Red Dead Redemption so what
are your thoughts on the ending of Red
Dead Redemption - did you go for the
money or save John comment below and let
me know and if you enjoyed this video
then please like it and subscribe to my
channel make sure you check out my
breakdown of the ending of call of duty
black ops 4 which will be linked at the
end of this one and if you want to
support our channel so we can bring you
more content like this and please donate
to the patreon linked in the description
this is a channel for the hardcore
players so if video games are the kind
of thing you like hits
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
you